I've had to push people out of my
company because the best thing for them
to do is not be with me but that's a
problem because sometimes people just
get they love the culture and they love
the energy and they love to believe and
it's like the greatest place they've
ever worked and the opportunities and
just the vibe is so high and the
teamwork is not like people yelling at
each other but dude your dream is to go
do this like you can't be doing this
with me anymore and you have to kick
them out so they can actually go chase
down their dreams yeah so we've had to
do that to a couple people everybody
wants to serve you know if you're not
serving you're not happy and some people
want to serve the world and some people
want to serve the closest people to them
I want to serve the world if you felt
like today you're going to wake up and
you weren't going to serve it doesn't
matter if you show up today you go to
work whatever nobody cares that's the
path down to depression anxiety suicide
all of that cuz you feel like you don't
matter to anybody yeah but if you felt
like today I was going to do something
that would matter to somebody whether
it's the world or one person you're like
today is going to mean something to
somebody else that's how you get to
purpose and happiness and
fulfillment
welcome to the very first episode of the
standout I'm here with my very first
guest Evan Carmichael I thought you
going to say you're very close friend
but I'll take your very first guess we
became friends just recently very
quickly so yesterday we spoke about um
you you did a test because you started
to show um the things that I suck at or
something like that tell me why I suck
tell me why I suck where you bring on
people experts in their craft to come on
and show you or illuminate areas where
you may suck or may want to improve and
one of them was um kind of figuring out
all the things that are disbelief or
things that come up that are negative
thought processes and instead of
immediately replacing them with a
positive thought um you just sit with
them instead because you trained
yourself whenever a negative thought
comes in you immediately replace it with
a positive one and it seems like it
serves you because you are a successful
entrepreneur um except grief that's the
only one but everything else yes gotcha
yeah and so when did you start the habit
of replacing those negative thoughts
with positive ones and then when did you
start to see them take root and actually
manifest in your life I don't know that
I made a conscious choice that like now
I'm going to replace this thought with
this thought I think it's just as a
result of being in the industry so long
watching so many like if you think about
what I do and how many videos I watch of
how many successful people they all have
some core themes to them and whether
it's entrepreneurs or athletes or
artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade or turning lemons into
lemonade you know turning a negative
into a positive is is a consistent theme
across everybody and so I think it just
it happened
subconsciously just by being in the
environment enironment of having those
people around me virtually to the point
where I was doing that exercise being
forced to sit with negative thoughts and
it it I had changed but I didn't notice
like I don't there was no moment of
coming out of the Cocoon and now I'm a
butterfly it just slowly became here I
am as a butterfly gotcha so it was just
going through the process yeah it's it's
like imagine if you were working out
your legs every day you don't you don't
you don't see a daytoday
there's no one moment like oh you did
one extra hard set and now you've got
these Rippling Cales ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you but it's not that
you can pinpoint one thing that that was
the moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative
It's Just Happening yeah and so that's
the power of when you shift your
environment and you're controlling what
you're consuming into your you know into
your brain so I was conscious of what I
was consuming I wasn't conscious about a
lot of the transformation that happened
as a result it's only in looking back or
doing exercises like that um that I
notice the difference I mentioned grief
as a caveat because that's the only one
that I don't think you can you can just
positive your way out of sure you know
like I think you just have to feel your
way through grief at least me you know I
have I haven't lost my parents so that's
awesome but um my family dog was like
that was the only time I haven't made
videos in the past 10 years was when my
family dog passed away wow uh because he
died on filming day and I just couldn't
film and I I could have if it was
anything else if I was jealous if it was
angry if I got cut off on traffic if I
lost a bunch of subscribers I don't know
something else happen like okay come on
let's go car like film but I just didn't
feel right to push past it to film you
know like I film with a concussion and a
broken neck and all this other stuff but
when when Toby passed like I don't know
it doesn't feel right to just brush it
away and so I just have to feel this
yeah it's just one of those things that
you need to sit in because if you push
it away then maybe it manifests in
something other than what you want it to
come out at yeah I didn't overthink it
and I'm not neing this is descriptive
for other people to follow it was just
for me in the moment it actually it
feels right to move from something
negative happening to switch into
positivity as soon as I can like if I'm
if I'm if I have a negative thought like
I'm never going to make it okay that
right away even me saying that it's like
I'm going to make it of course I'm going
to make it like like it's such a like
half a second switch already to the
positive and that feels good it feels
right like I I like that um but when I
when I did that with Toby Dy it's like
it didn't feel right didn't feel right
so I just didn't do it but I didn't
overthink of like if I don't do this in
a year I'm going to regret or whatever
right just it just didn't feel right I
guess it's the five stages of grief you
don't just go from recognition or the
whatever that first stage is all the way
to the end with skipping the other ones
it's it's there for a reason because
it's taking us through something maybe I
mean I don't even know what the stages
are but um yeah again like I'm I'm not
as like book smart uh knowing
everybody's methodologies it's just
doing what I feel Works gotcha and the
the point that you made about it's just
like going to the gym working out legs
clearly I need to work out my legs
you're still probably better than me on
my leg so
although I'm probably the opposite
because I'm on a
trampoline and we'll jump 20 to 40,000
times a day uh and so my calves are
pretty legit but my upper body is where
I need to
trade so the trampoline to you is
push-ups to me it seems like maybe you
do way more jumps than I do push-ups
yeah okay uh but before the episode I
just did some push-ups get the blood
flowing get ready get my mind right get
my body right for the interview um and
now you have your own method to get the
blood flowing yep we're jumping um but
what you're saying is like staying in
the gym is what gets you to that process
and you just displayed perfectly
like even just saying it even it's not
man it's not even real but just saying
I'm never going to make it boom your
mind is already at the point to where
that is not a thing that's not how we
operate no let's switch that to a
positive just shows the mental strength
that you've gone through not just by
it's not just a thing that you sit down
and do but through experience but also
monitoring what you consume yeah I don't
I don't even think it's um mental
strength uh I don't think I went through
anything really uh but it's all it was
all subconscious like in looking back
it's all subconscious like if you if you
took a gym and then your condo was like
right beside the gym like in the same
building and you had to walk through the
gym to get to your condo every day
you're going to start working out more
yeah cuz you're going to see other
people working out more you don't even
need to come up with a plan of like how
many push-ups do I do when do I do hit
training or strength training or you
know cardio or machine or free weights
or whatever like you you'll just start
doing it because it's around you so much
yeah and and most people's environments
are designed to keep them small not not
that they have designed it themselves it
has been architected by
others right it's been architected by
your parents it's been architected by
whoever had the place before you you
know like that your place has not been
architected so you can if you just
change the environment and that's what
you what you consume that's who you
follow I was doing a podcast today
talking about how how negative social
media is it's like not mine yeah I go to
my Instagram and it's amazing all
positive I go to my YouTube channel it's
like awesome same right well why well
because I'm not following people who are
spreading negativity like you you you
could easily go and find lots of
negative accounts to go off and follow I
don't watch their stff as soon to
something negative I'm I'm swiping away
I don't want that in my algorithm I
don't want you feeding me more of that
crap next Gone Gone Gone right and same
thing for YouTube yeah and a lot of
times whether it's parents friends
people that are close to us they don't
necessarily mean to design an
environment that is negative for us but
we need to have the recognition of this
isn't serving me anymore so yeah and
even maybe maybe negative is not always
the right word I'd say your your
environment's been designed to keep you
where you are gotcha and when you it it
seems like from a younger age After High
School once you um started working on
your business with your partners you
were entrepreneurial minded what did you
do in your environment to kind of get
rid of besides the news the TV what kind
of things did you remove from your life
and still have removed from your life to
make sure that you're designing your
environment properly for
optimal uh so I might answer that in two
different ways you look at like being in
University starting the business versus
now because in University there was no
Instagram or YouTube for me I didn't
have a a cell phone um and I also wasn't
a News Junkie
like there's a war happening there's
like an oil crisis there's a somebody
somebody was assassinated there's a ride
somewhere like does like I don't know
yeah like I'm not I'm uh I used to judge
myself for not being in the no on a lot
of these things it's like I don't I
don't I don't care sure you know um I'm
focused on other things things and so I
was never a news junky where like I felt
like I had to know what was going on and
so I didn't really have a lot of uh
negative stimulus yeah um but I read
books like I just tried to read books of
people that inspired me cuz my parents
are not entrepreneurs right
so they're my heroes and now they taught
me how to be a human believe in others
and caring and compassion and all my
values that make me who I am like the
reason why I invited you here is because
of my parents you know like the push to
say come and let's do it now even the
offer like it's all that's my parents
speaking through yeah but they're not
entrepreneurs they don't know about
business you know it's not um I had to
go off and learn that somewhere else and
so I injected books at the time um if
you look at it now I'm a lot more aware
of how important environment is you know
I didn't even know when I was in was
1920 started the company 19 yeah um so
now it's being conscious of who I
surround myself with events that I go to
what videos I watch there's a channel
that I love that I've Loved for years
and their content shifted in the past
three months to go a lot more negative
sure I stopped watching their
videos and it's a close friend of mine
gotta and it hurts but it's like dude
now I feel worse watching your videos
but it's doing better okay it's getting
more views sure yeah but it's but I
don't like it anymore bad travel seven
times F it's a lot more negative and
like feeding into the fear and
everything else it's like I don't I
don't want that for me yeah and so it's
being conscious of those things and and
unsubscribing and unfollowing and stop
watching that content and then being
around people who lift you up yeah you
know like being here to make this happen
cuz you have to go home tonight you're
driving like 6 hours you to get home at
like midnight or 1:00 a.m. or whatever
uh hopefully the border is not too crazy
for you but you had to move things
around or you know change your life to
stay for this I had to cancel three
interviews today to make this happen
today why well because I wanted to spend
more time with you because hopefully
this you know helps you leads to
something gives you more belief whatever
like again not overthinking or judging
is like I like this guy I want to help
him and so it's worth it yes and those
things pay off you know like we'll be
yeah 10 years later we'll come back he's
like remember that first episode we did
at your dance studio and like I almost
uh almost show up I was a 90day guy and
like all this right and and not it
doesn't always work out like I've had
people where I'm their first episode and
then they never post it right they never
post the episode we film it and they
never post it and then they never launch
anything that will not be me well but
but whatever it's like the gift the gift
is the moment whether whatever happens
afterwards H happens right but it's a
conscious choice to to to when you find
somebody uh a human in life uh
a video a channel that you want to
subscribe to like just be around it more
like make a conscious choice to be
around it more and there's so many
different people that you can meet and
so many different channels you can
subscribe to or accounts that you can
follow if something hits you in some
kind of way like
just make an effort to be around it more
now it's easy with with YouTube or
Instagram or whatever just follow the
account then unfollow the other account
with humans it's trying to find like
it's awkward sometimes right like ask
the person for coffee you know you be
the one to try to stay in touch with
them and ask them how they're doing um
even this it's like I offered to do I
don't know what you're doing tomorrow or
today I didn't know what you were up to
right I didn't know what I was up to
dude I had no idea what I was up to I
agreed to do an interview knowing that
it's probably a crazy day but I didn't
know who we'd be canceling on what time
and whatever right and listen if it was
really bad I would have said hey man
like sure you got to talk to Alex
instead of me or what we figure you can
always make it up right like worst case
I can't do it and we do a zoom or I fly
to Ohio or whatever right
um but it's the conscious choice to when
you find someone that you like and you
want to spend more time with to to spend
more time with them because it it can
make a huge impact on on your
perspective on your energy on your
motivation on on the output you can just
go so much like if you look at this this
was going to happen how long were you
thinking about doing a podcast um
at least a year so you've been thinking
about doing it for a year you meet us we
talk about it now you give yourself a
90-day deadline and and now we're here
like you've done more in one day than
you've done in the past year yeah that's
right right and that's that's the same
for a lot of these things right like how
many people want to start our YouTube
channel or want to start going to the
gym or want to start like if somebody
came to you and said hey I want to I
want to go to the gym like ah yeah you
know I'm been putting on these pounds
want to go to the gym whatever but that
but we get stuck in our heads of well
what gym do I join and what exercises
and like what you know how about diet
and do I need do I do the keto or do I
do the carnivore or do I do the the
vegan or and I need tools right like I
need to get I need weights I guess or do
I need the Home Gym my God or do I need
to go to a gym but then I need a trainer
and all of a sudden you're like you
talked yourself out you created all
these Ro but if they were around you
you'd be like dude let's do push-ups
together and in them doing like four and
a half push-ups which might be their Max
right mhm they've done more working out
with you in in like eight minutes than
in the past five years of their life
right so like that's the power being
around people who who energize you and
push you like we've done this episode
now you've done more on this than in the
past year yeah right and that's how
people can you can level up with them
and it what you're talking about reminds
me of something uh I can't remember who
said it but sometimes you have to ride
other people's belief in you until yours
kicks in yeah and it seems like you're
just a big edifier like you just want to
push people forward and if something
comes from it great if nothing comes
from it then you did whatever you wanted
to do in that moment and because it's
also a gift for me yeah right it's like
whether I'm I could be completely
delusional too right I'm I'm I'm okay
with that like I could be completely I
think you need to be a little I could be
but so like people I've shared examples
of you know I was somebody's first guest
on show I did the same thing that I did
for them that we're doing right now and
then they never post and then people ask
no most people post but well like why
would you waste your time with that
person like it wasn't a waste of time
yeah because that was a gift for me to
serve and I still help them in the
moment give them belief to be able to do
something whether whether they end up
continuing on or maybe they realize that
content creation isn't for them or
whatever I don't know why they don't I'm
not following up and like pissed that
they didn't post
whatever else um but that was a gift and
and I helped them level up in that
moment and that I believe will have
Ripple effects out into anything else
that they like we've taken to another
level that then is going to help them
pop in another are of their life and
maybe that's maybe that's not true but
at least I tell myself that that's true
so then it's not it's not a waste of
time it was a sure it was awesome yeah
and whether if it doesn't happen it's
just like the news just like those
negative not that that that's a negative
situation but you don't even let it
affect you you don't let what's going on
out here it's a switch to positive like
back to the first question it's like
it's just an instant switch to the
positive right so like the three people
I canceled on today to do this I mean I
didn't can my team messaged them so
hope whether you are or not right it's
like uh I'm assuming we can reschedule
maybe we maybe we can maybe we can't I
don't know maybe they're pissed
hopefully not like I think I can always
make it up to somebody if I if I piss
somebody off cuz it's not intentional uh
I mean worst case somebody's like super
pissed I can't believe it I rented this
studio you're supposed to come on yada
yada yada you know I would say I'll make
it up to you come to Toronto and make it
happen I would make you make them a
personal video to say dude I'm so sorry
but like here's what happened right and
like and then it'd be good right and if
they can't make sense of that then I
wouldn't get along with that person
anyway right so there's always a like
everything is savable in the worst case
scenario and the upside is so tremendous
right and one of the things I learned
from you last night at David meltzer's
VIP dinner uh cuz you were on the panel
yeah was creating a list of a 100 people
that you'd like to stay in contact with
and then following up with them at least
90 days so it just kind of shows even if
you screwed up or not necessarily
screwed up say you cancel on these three
people you hit them up on the next
90-day touch whenever that comes around
they're probably going to respond and
they'll probably respond in a positive
way yeah those people aren't on my list
but sure but
yes sorry for those who are not on his
list of 100 well it's 300 people it's
300 now yeah okay am I on the list or uh
not yet we'll see we'll see where that
goes we'll see like but Dave is so I
sent the picture it's funny Dave I sent
a picture to Dave of us at the at the
dinner because we had dinner together he
wanted to sit next to me so we did that
and then and I WR to him says thanks for
your energy yesterday Dave I appreciate
you when it's always an honor pouring
into people alongside you and then he
wrote
back I loved it talk to you within 90
days that's awesome now Dave Dave was
Dave was on the list and I talked to
Dave more than every 90 days but that's
like the worst case scenario cuz
sometimes that was designed for me
because I historically don't remember to
stay in touch with people sure and I
don't know how to stay in touch with
people yeah you know if I haven't talked
to you in 90 days I don't know what I
would I would like if I don't know well
I would probably ask you how your show's
doing or something if I Dave Meltzer or
whoever Gary ve or whoever I I feel like
it's a waste of time just to say hey
Gary like what's up yeah I suck at I
hate small talk as an introvert I hate
small talk and so I don't want to waste
somebody's time and so my solution has
been to one look at their stories on
Instagram and then comment on it there's
something on their story like hey that's
on the whatever that they just posted
and if they don't have any stories then
then my solution then this has saved me
is I just say hey happy Friday sending
you love from Canada and I put like a
heart emoji in a Canadian flag and it's
so well received that's awesome it's
crazy how well received it is cuz I
don't think many people just do that
even their friends I don't think they
get somebody just dropping love yeah and
then he's like hey and it shocks people
at first and they're like hey so um
like they're surprised that there's no
other there's no there's no second Punch
Yeah there's no obligation for them to
even respond but you're but there
surpris that there's no cuz usually it's
like hey how you doing but then there's
an ask right there's like I don't I
haven't been in touch with you for a
while okay I'm trying to sell my new
book right so hey how you doing man it's
like good good good yeah I got my new
book and like it be great to connect and
do something together which that's most
of what happens sure but then there's no
I got nothing to sell I'm just saying hi
like I'm just dropping love dropping
love from Canada that's great because
one of the I struggle with that too I'm
an extrovert but I like hey we make the
connection and then when we're not in
that interaction anymore I've gone on to
want to meet the next person and then
the next person the next person um which
is probably why sometimes I even
struggle to start things like this
because I'm off to trying to figure out
the next thing even though I haven't
committed to building whatever that
first thing was um but it's a great way
to do it hey just want to let you know
that I'm thinking about you and that
language that's like every other wording
felt weird because hey how you doing or
hey what are you working on hey can I
support you with something you're doing
it felt like too transactional or a
waste of time like if it's hey how you
doing just felt like a waste of time and
and hey can I help you with something it
feels like there's going to be uh like
they're expecting me to ask going to
drop yeah and so I like it it's just
that that language or that verbiage of
hey just dropping you some love from
Canada happy Friday
yeah it just works great that's good and
uh one of the things I was listening to
you talk about was your wife Nina y her
Chief heart officer role in the business
was to incorporate more Family Values
more keeping the schedule making sure
everyone's in the know of what's going
on is that would you say that those two
things are connected with your 100 day
list keeping in touch with people but
also incorporating touch points within
your business because you have 42
employees um how does how do those
things kind of translate into your
business so I'm great
at really shining a light on somebody
when I'm with
them and then I go away you know and
then it's like oh but I'm left alone
like what do I do right sure right he's
like we're making your podcast yeah we
are and you're going to go home tomorrow
he like oh but like where's the lights
and where's Dominic and where's Alex to
help me and like who's going to bring
the ch and like who what
you right uh and and so it'd be this
like when I come in it's it's
um uh like a burst of energy and then it
kind of goes away and it really depends
on the projects that I'm working on and
so you know my team I meet usually more
than every 90 days but um what a lot of
people need especially you when you go
to uh a more employee mindset they need
more
friendship and I
am I am weird in this um and the best
explanation of it was uh from Shah ruk
Khan if you know sha ruk Khan he's he's
one of the most famous actors in India
okay it's like the Tom Cruz of India oh
wow king of bwood and he had a quote
that just like struck me in one of the
videos we did on him and he says I
connect with people through the work and
so he's doing his acting shows and the
movie's done and his friends are his
cast are like hey like we're all going
to go and party we're all going to go
whatever and he's like no I'm I'm good
like I love you but like I don't want to
just hang out conect with people through
the
work I was like that's what I love doing
like I connect with people through the
work I don't want to just I don't know
even know what hanging out is sure I
don't know what that means I'm weird but
so you know so shyr Khan and I might be
the only two weird people in the world
but I like this like yeah like I can
deeply connect with somebody through the
work yeah it's kind of like doing life
together because a lot of your life
probably the majority of your life is
working do I have that right so like
you're just doing life with those people
yeah and so I remember um Alex who's
here in the studio he runs this business
Tron D salsa uh he was engaged uh in a
different
Lifetime and his fiance also kind of
worked in the school and was helping
teach and stuff and um she came to me
and she
said uh that she wanted to spend more
time with me like get to know me and and
it's like I'm not a good like I don't
want to do
that it's like I'm not good at
friendships like I don't know what if
you want to talk about the business like
yeah happy or if you need me for
something like hey I need your help with
like something yeah I'm there like I'm
the first one in but to just hang out
and I don't know cards or something it's
like I'm not or whatever like I don't
know what the I don't want to do that
like it's just not F I would be forcing
myself to go do that thing and it's not
me but most people like that stuff like
I'm the weird one and so back to your
question nah is great at facilitating
those kinds of things so she's the one
checking in on people and asking about
their relationships and asking about
like how their mom is doing and like
she's the glue for a lot of this stuff
yeah um and I it's a big weakness you
know it works really well with high
achieving entrepreneurs but a lot of
people in your team will not be high
achievement entrepreneurs sure right and
so they they need that extra level of
connection and Nina's like way better at
it than I am she compliments your
weaknesses with her strengths yeah yeah
cuz she she's everybody wants to
serve you know you know if you're not
serving you're not happy and some people
want to serve the world and some people
want to serve the closest people to them
I want to serve the world yeah NE wants
to serve the 20 closest people to her
and so combined it works great that's
amazing that's a really good mix but
everybody wants to serve you know like
if you if you felt like today you're
going to wake up and you weren't going
to serve like you it doesn't matter if
you show up today you go to work
whatever nobody cares that's the path
down to depression anxiety suicide all
of that cuz you feel like you don't
matter to anybody yeah but if you felt
like today I was going to do something
that would matter to somebody whether
it's the world or one person like I
today is going to mean something to
somebody
else that's how you get to purpose and
happiness and fulfillment and I kind of
want to unpack that a little bit because
obviously you're very Mission focused
and your mission is to solve the world's
number one toughest problem which is
people's belief in themselves right and
then you're matched up with Nina who who
wants to serve the close people that are
around her MH and when business owners
entrepreneurs are out there and they
want to incorporate their spouse into
their business and whether it's it's
either going well not going well or
they're just thinking about it what are
some of the things that um in alignment
with how you guys operate that you would
suggest for them to make sure before you
do this these are the types of things
that you should think about on how how
well you can
communicate people say don't work with
friends and family I love it I think
it's the best the best dude I think it's
great okay if you can't have
conversations then that leads to passive
aggressiveness and bitterness and anger
and all this other stuff right and
so you either get down to a values
difference or an inability to
communicate what I mean by that is what
I mean by that is um you know when when
I came up here I asked Alex hey what
time did what time did Trevor show up
right and and it end up you were 2
minutes late right it's like okay that's
not that's not how we roll right right
and so either uh no whatever like I
don't really care but if we were hanging
out more that would not fly right and
so either we just disagree on that right
like you don't it doesn't matter to you
and it matters to me in which case like
we wouldn't keep working together but we
wouldn't be friends like I'm not friends
with people who are late on
things or there's an inability to
communicate meaning like I couldn't tell
you that dude like you can't be late
right and we couldn't communicate that
which is where most people like they
actually share similar values because
that's why you married them or that's
why you're a friend but you can't
communicate around the things that mean
something to you and if you can't have
hard conversations then I mean you're
going to struggle as a boss in general
but um I love working with family it's
it's the best and have you always been
able to just have those tough
conversations because I know that I've
personally struggled with having those
tough conversations I know when it's
necessary but it doesn't it's not a
right away thing like for you you came
in here boom hey that's not how we roll
right uh for me it's like hey you know
we like to show up on
time well so it depends like you get
people at the beginning I remember we
had an instructor here who was working
uh at the studio and uh I forget if he
showed up if he just completely forgot
about a meeting or showed up like half
an hour late or whatever and Alex was
saw it or heard about it and then it's
like how come you gave him like so much
leeway like if if it were him one minute
late I'm gone right but with with you
know it's like why are you not here yeah
cuz it's not only my standard it's his
standard right it's like what are you
teaching yourself if it's okay to be
late for things but this new guy was
like half an hour late or completely
forgot and didn't show up or whatever
because I haven't built the the the
Rapport the respect the trust yet to go
hard on him because if you just show up
and you're
hard there's they think you're just uh
you know a jerk yeah a jerk yeah they
just think you're a jerk like yesterday
when when you did this you did this uh
MC at this event with Dave and after
everybody's telling hey great job like
yeah it was really awesome and and we
were talking we're walking I don't know
he was a for meeting you I said hey you
open to some feedback MH and you said
yeah yeah give it to me absolutely in in
a very not like a yeah sure you know
like I don't want exactly right and so
then it became a bunch of like hard
pushes on things and the more you were
receptive to things the deeper we went
and more ideas came and more like dude
you have to do this so that when when I
walked in here and asked if if you what
time you came up it was like okay like
we we've already established a
relationship now around that where you
know I'm not being an ass and I and I
love you and want to see you win so that
allows like I think the deeper you are
to to somebody the more you you can push
them and the more everybody can grow
yeah you can't bring a reckoning without
a relationship because it's the love
that allows you to push harder yeah like
the harder I am on Alex it's only
because he knows that I love like it's
on a foundation of love and want to see
him win that gives me the permission to
go and push harder with somebody who I
don't know very well I'm I'm super just
believe you know like hey good job hey
next time you'll do better whatever
right it's like it's very surface level
which is still like that's still more
encouragement than most people get ever
but but the closer that you get to me
the more becomes a push cuz if somebody
if if you don't know that they love you
it comes across as you are a j JK yeah
when people saw videos like Alex and I
did a couple videos before of like
Mentor sessions and people would leave
comments I didn't realize everyone was
such a jerk or like comments kind of
like that cuz they're seeing a window
that like Alex wants that he's grateful
for that right like you're grateful for
the the push yesterday and taking a
notes right but to an outsider it's like
what's even what am I stepping into here
right because it is actually Bel it's
just a deeper version of believe because
I believe in what you could do so much
and that people sitting telling you how
great you are is actually not helpful to
you get to become the person that you
want to be right and so if you're
willing to go on a journey then like
this is actually a faster path to get
there right right it's an
uncomfortability but you have to
establish a sense of Love first like
this person is actually not criticizing
me as a human they love me and they want
to see me win yeah people don't care
what you know until they know how much
you care that's perfect example um and
yeah you just said hey can I offer are
you open to some feedback if you just
came up to me and said hey this is what
you did wrong and you should probably do
these things better maybe I wouldn't
have been receptive to it but you just
asked the question and of course I was
open to it because I want to get better
well maybe not of course most people are
not you know super open to it but uh but
I wouldn't have asked if I didn't get a
vibe that you might be but I still asked
where Alex like if he if he did that
like dude that sucked like are you your
game what's wrong with you today right
it'd be
like that's but like what am I watching
here like I've come into classes here
he's like can you come and watch my
class and it's like it's the same
feedback that I gave no I think Alex is
the if if someone needs to learn uh
absolute beginner love with salsa like
from nothing I would I would bet money
and Alex to give the best experience of
anybody in the world wow like I would I
I would put money on him going up
against somebody else right for what for
what he does cool great so that's that's
the foundation now I come to your class
he wants feedback he like dude this is
the same feedback I gave you six months
ago like sure you haven't done the thing
I told you I'm not coming unless you're
working on the thing I told you to do
six months ago right this is a waste of
time yeah it makes sense right yeah but
it's like but he wants to grow and get
better and do this thing so when
everybody's telling him this is like as
you get better at something there's
going to be fewer people who can teach
you and more people who just tell you
how good you
are what you respect the most is like
who's going to help me it's easy to
level up to go from like a a two to a
four or whatever to a seven but like
it's gets harder and harder and harder
because there's fewer people who can
tell you what you need to get to the
next level um both just information wise
and most people are telling you how good
you are yeah and so you just stay this
big fish in this small pond right and by
you asking me that or provid hey these
are the things that I saw you do well
these are the things that I saw you do
not so well now from my perspective
you're somebody who pays attention
you're somebody who cares enough to even
one take the time to say something but
pay attention during the entire thing
because you just have an um a
perspective to kep pick up on those
things and then do something about it um
which I think is super helpful and I'm
glad to be sitting here and that's why
we're sitting here right now that's why
we're sitting here if you said no or
whatever like okay whatever cool like
lots of love next um thank you next
and he
gone guess he'll never get those big
strong legs
now um but another question I had is um
you know earlier in your journey when
you were uh work as working as an
entrepreneur in your business the the
very first business that you were part
of it was uh science software technology
and you came to a point where it was
just so tough you weren't making any
progress $300 a month
and couldn't figure out any way to make
some traction and you decided I quit um
but the next day you're like NOP can't
quit yet got to keep pushing um because
you had a phone call with your partner
the night before and just said hey this
isn't for me I'm out um when you came
back because you came back with a plan
with bringing on a virtual Mentor not
necessarily somebody that you could
touch and reach but somebody you could
learn from Bill Gates because he had a
software company that he built from zero
to what it is now but you looked at the
very beginning when you came back to the
business how did that invigorate your
partners especially once you got that
first sale when you partnered with
somebody
so I don't know how much it invigorated
them I don't i' never had the
conversation to be honest I was more
concerned just about me coming back and
I think back to your previous question I
think this is why it's so great to work
with people who you love and have a deep
relationship with because I told him the
night before that I quit that I feel
worthless this is not working out that
his ideas weren't working and I need to
feel like I'm a valuable human so I'm
out that's hard to hear right like he's
struggling too he's trying to build this
business up he's not happy with where
it's going and now the guy who's like
the business guy is is quitting on him
sure so I decided you know again not to
live with regret somebody else has done
it I didn't have a plan the next day
apart from Bill Gates had built the
software company I'm going to learn how
Bill Gates did it and I'm going to try
to apply it like that was my plan it was
a very loose like it was just more of a
I felt like I had tried everything and
then I realized oh there's like this
other thing I haven't tried yet so it
gave me a little bit of Hope and I I
remember walking like going to uh his
apartment we all worked out of his
apartment and uh I didn't know how he
was going to react I just quit on him
the day before telling him I felt
worthless and this was going nowhere and
here I am like back at work yeah let's
get back on the horse right and I was
really afraid that he would you know not
let me in not like we'd have to have
this whole conversation or whatever and
I didn't tell him I was coming it was no
like hey by the way sorry man you know
right I just showed up and he open the
door and he looked at
me and then we just moved on you know
it's like just one of those got it yeah
he just is like okay like wow that was
so much easier it's like okay like now
maybe he's carrying some trauma or
residual something as I don't know I
haven't asked him but like for me that
was a huge relief and that you know I
would I guess hypothesize that he
understood how stressful everything was
yeah but that I still cared for him
cared for the business wanted to see it
work and so I'm back and we didn't need
to have this giant conversation cuz if
it's somebody that you don't know and
then they quit on you and then they come
back it's like why are you you either
you're in or you're out well it's like
if if somebody worked for you for a day
and then quit and then show up the next
day you're either going to just not let
them in M right it's like dude like
forget it like you're not you're not
staying here I got work to do I need
people who are reliable or you're going
to have a conversation like why did you
leave yesterday and then have to go
through this whole process uh but with
someone that you know better it's like
okay I get it it wasn't it wasn't
personal we don't need to dive into this
let's just get back to work yeah so he
said everything without saying anything
and then I just went in and we got back
to work so and it seems like that was a
fairly good partnership like between you
guys like what did you learn from that
partnership that you've applied to
Future
Partnerships um similar values mhm you
know uh and then
also talk about difficult conversations
and similar values so like we all we had
a vision for what we wanted to do with
the company we all had similar values we
complemented our skills nicely between
between us or three of us um and then we
reached a point where they wanted to
sell the
company and I didn't want to sell the
company
uh but the most important reason was
that it was more personal reason like
they wanted to get to
California and live in California was
like a main that was a big driver okay
and doing some things like counting how
CL how many cloudy days there were in
Toronto and all this stuff and it's like
they just wanted to get to California
and at the end of the day it's like you
know what this is your dream to go live
there
personally I don't want to
I don't want to be in the way of that
and it's not worth fighting over yeah so
let's sell wow and we sold and they both
went to California and I stayed here and
then I started doing other things gotcha
but that's a hard conversation yeah
definitely definitely and people I love
and like we built this thing from
nothing and
um I don't regret it I mean I again like
then it just becomes okay where are we
going next as opposed to thinking where
what I could have done or where we could
have been or whatever else like I could
not build it without
them I couldn't do it like I'm I was the
business guy I'm not a science guy I
don't know how to figure out the
software yeah so and I don't want to be
the guy holding them back from doing
anybody like if the best thing I've had
to push people out of my company because
the best thing for them to do is not be
with me sure like but that's a that's a
problem because sometimes people just
get um they love the culture and they
love the energy and they love to believe
and it's like the greatest place they've
ever worked and the opportunities and
just the vibe is so high and the
teamwork is not like people yelling at
each other but dude your dream is to go
do this like you can't be doing this
with me anymore right and you have to
kick them out so they can actually go
chase down their dreams yeah so we've
had to do that to a couple people and
maybe you selling that company with
those
Partners who knows where you'd be now if
the the believe brand would be here in
the way that it is now for sure I don't
think that way but yes sure you know
yeah like what would have happened if I
had did this in what parallel universe
whatever just grateful for that the way
that it did happen and that you are
where you are now yeah I mean yeah yeah
onwards and speaking of that you've done
a lot on YouTube you have almost 4
million subscribers on YouTube um and I
think it was Gary ve who said you're
kind of like a DJ who takes the best
things that people have put out and and
spin in a way that people can go and
consume positive inspiring motivational
content um and it's just been really
inspirational for a lot of people which
is why I think your channel has had a
lot of success um but usually when
people wrap up um interviews or
conversations they ask the
interviewee um you know where can people
find stuff about you and I'm sure
there's a ton of different places where
people can find stuff about you because
you're a coach you're a mentor you have
a mastermind you have your YouTube
channel but if you could send somebody
to one thing whether it's on your
YouTube channel this one video like if
you could send people to one place to
get the most value where would you send
them Trevor's second
video check out the channel baby we're
going live it's not going to come out in
90 days it's going to be soon oh no I'm
gonna well Dominic H Evan's camera guy
is actually coming back to Ohio with me
he's packing up his gear he doesn't know
that he's smiling right
now
yeah no I mean the best thing that
people can do is support this channel
you know and if you like the questions
that he asked and the the vibe and the
style and where he's going it's only
going to get better like this is sure
the next video might not have the
lighting or whatever but in terms of the
the questions any the interaction like
this is the worst that it's going to be
because as you keep doing this it'll
just keep getting better so if you like
this interview subscribe to the channel
leave a comment let them know and then
go support him on the future videos that
come out
awesome thank you very much Evan I
really appreciate it man let's go to see
me coaching another entrepreneur
one-onone check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there